so yes this is me
at my day job detecting bugs yeah so I
work at wetransfer as a front-end
engineer and team Li and for me that
means that I write mostly react HTML CSS
a little bit of Ruby everyone again and
I also manage a team of six and I'm
responsible for the day-to-day delivery
for that team and this is also me about
six years ago I was helping run a
workshop for young girls in New Zealand
which is yeah where I'm from and yes I'm
a very long way away from home but the
idea was that we would get these young
women into the company to sort of show
them what it was actually like to be a
software engineer
they were about 14 years old and they
were all in the same tech class at
school and honestly I think we kind of
blew their minds on how cool this [ __ ]
actually is compared to what they were
learning and but yeah I really want to
encourage people to do as many of these
kinds of programs as you can because
it's incredibly rewarding and also
inspirational because this was one of
the inspirations for this talk having
worked with junior devs quite a lot it's
one of these things that I've noticed is
they really struggle with debugging and
I think that's kind of because we don't
really teach it as a skill it's one of
those things that you sort of expect
developers to just pick up naturally and
there's so much there to learn if you
really focus on that and that's why I
decided to write this talk hopefully
there will be something useful in here
no matter how deep down this hole you've
been before but err yeah so a quick look
at the process itself how often have you
actually spent time thinking about how
you debug it's easy to forget that it's
a difficult skill that it's it's
something that you need to master in
order to become a really experienced
developer and it's learnt over time and
improve with experience and it's not
just about the tools you use but it's
the mindset in the process and how you
actually work through your debugging
tasks and it becomes particularly clear
when we compare those new developers
with more experienced ones often new
developers will jump
straight into the code they'll go and
change a whole bunch of things they
won't remember what they've changed and
what they haven't and what actually
might have fixed the problem and what
was maybe just some extra bit of code
that they stuck in there that wasn't
useful at all but it's something we do
pretty much every single day and so in
this talk I won't go into the detail of
how important it is to reproduce the bug
be methodical only change one thing at a
time how to narrow down where the bug is
but it's surprising how often the stuff
is not taught so if you're a junior
developer or you're teaching junior
developers I hope you're one of either
of these two things
ya do spend the time really looking into
this stuff with them so there is one
step that I do want to cover really
quickly because even the most senior
developers I've worked with and
including myself sometimes I forget to
write tests like this is the first thing
that you do right if you've discovered a
bug write a test that reproduces it
because it not only will keep your focus
on just that one bug it'll also speed
you up because you no longer need to
launch your app and click about to get
to the state of where your bug actually
is and of course it'll help your bug can
never return so let's move on to the
tools starting with the console well the
polls are in as you can see we've got
56% of developers on the left-hand side
use console.log
and 67 on the right-hand side and it's
it's not surprising right because we've
been conditioned to use it alongside
simple text editors like sublime text
atom notepad etc and a large portion of
web developers have also just simply
missed the exposure to a formal or
Street or structured debugging process
like myself and the browser consult is a
pretty nice way to inspect the results
of your logs
so it works and and it's easy well why
change it well because there is so much
more so even if we just take a closer
look at console Tarlac you'll see that
there are lots of different ways to
optimize it so here on top we have the
normal console dot log usage for logging
out these two variables pin 1 and pin
- and here they yeah but on the bottom
if you just add two extra cat characters
to turn this log into an object yeah you
not only get the results of the log but
of the the value of the variable but you
also get the variable context so it's
much easier to see at a glance what
you're logging it can be really useful
especially when you're logging a lot of
different things in your application and
you can also really add easily add
styling to your lives by including this
percentage sign see at the beginning and
then passing through some styling as the
second parameter you can get really
pretty colors so sticking to the console
for now did you know that there are
actually a whole bunch of different more
methods on that object so I'm gonna show
you my favorites but googling will
reveal a hell of a lot more for instance
console table is super useful if you
want to log out an array of objects so
here you can see it's much easier to
kind of compare at a glance the
different values and next we have
console group which is when I don't know
about you but have you ever ended up
adding so many logs in your application
that you can't tell which was the one
that you just added
well group and group collapse are really
useful for structuring your logs and to
collapsible groups creating less noise
in the console for you to analyze which
is really the aim of game another useful
function you can use in the console is
the dollar selector so it works
similarly similarly to the jQuery
selector it's an alias for the document
selector function in the console if you
include a 0 after it as I've done here
you can get the most recently inspected
HTML element or JavaScript object a 1
gets you the second most recently
selected etc etc up to 4 super useful if
you want to quickly see what properties
or attributes are on the Dom node or
JavaScript objects that you're looking
at and if you use Dola Dola it's the
equivalent of document query selector or
even better it returns you a proper
array rather than a node list so you can
manipulate it straight away console dot
trace has been a lifesaver for me
especially when you're working in a new
code base and you can't actually you
don't have that you know inherent
knowledge of what is calling what and so
in here I added a consult up trace on
this handle filter click function to
figure out what was calling it and you
can see that it's now telling me that it
was called by a handle click in filter
jeaious and consular is great when you
want to inspect a Dom node as a
JavaScript object rather than as its
markup which is what console.log returns
you so you can see all the properties on
that Dom node much more easily and no
though it's even more useful as you can
see console logs let's spit out the
objects in black and white and it only
displays two levels deep consult order
on the other hand allows you to add some
really handy configuration so here we've
just added this extra object where we've
said colors true depth null and it means
that we get logs or pretty with lots of
different colors and you can now access
the lat and long properties on that geo
object so let's say we've been working
with console functions for a while and
want to step it up well let's dive into
the diff tools so I'm going to focus on
Chrome because it's what I'm most
familiar with but the Firefox dev tools
are also really great and have a lot of
the same functionality browser dev tools
have some really handy features for
debugging so the dev tools debugger is
the best one of them one of the simplest
ways to activate this is by using a
debugger keyword in your code so this
debugger keyword I typed this in into my
editor and opened it up in chrome and
when I refreshed it hit the debugger
keyword there at that break point and so
now you can see sorry I'm having video
issues as well but hopefully you'll be
able to see that we can log out the
value of the variables in scope at the
moment we can also inspect the entire
scope at this point of execution and we
can also step through the code
and speaking of stepping just in case
you've never used a debugger before here
are your main options they're pretty
much the same no matter what kind of
language you're writing or what kind of
tool you're using first we have resume
which is when you're on a breakpoint and
you press this and you'll be able to
resume the script until the next
breakpoint is hit if you hold this
button down you'll also have the option
to play through without hitting any more
breakpoints which can be useful when you
just want to get the code running the
next is step over which executes the
next function after your breakpoint and
stops afterwards and then we have the
step into and out of functions and note
that these are functions that we're
stepping over into and out of not lines
of code they can take a little bit to
kind of get that and yeah so what we've
been doing here is adding a line of code
breakpoint with the debugger keyword in
our IDE but if you set these breakpoints
in the dev tools or in your editor
you'll see where this can be much more
efficient than using console.log it's
almost as if you've peppered your whole
code base with console logs without
actually having to do so and having to
clean anything up simply click on the
line number so here I've clicked on 14
21 and 26 and then run your code as
usual and the execution will stop on
your set line of code break points which
you can then press resume to hit the
next one and go through as opposed to
needing to step through or over every
single function and when you're doing
this you may also want to use a watch
expression so that's what I've got here
on the right hand side I've just decided
to I've clicked the little plus button
there and I've just decided to watch
this dot state don't Mysteries because I
want to see what's happening to that
data and then as you step through the
code that expression will update so
you'll be able to see the value of
whatever you're watching there are lots
of different types of breakpoints and
you can see these as sit these directly
in the dev tools so for example example
we've got the line of code which is what
we've just been talking about
conditional line of code which I'll show
in a second daaamn so if a Dom node
changes xhr so if you want to break on a
particular HTTP request event listeners
exceptions and functions so here on the
left you can see how to add breakpoints
just on certain event listeners so here
just by ticking click there means that
anytime I click on my app a breakpoint
will be hit and then we have the Dom
nodes so here I'm gonna break on when a
Dom nodes attribute is modified and then
conditional breakpoints down the bottom
can be really useful for when a certain
function say a scroll hander or a react
render is called multiple times but you
only want to stop execution when
something has a certain value so here
I'm creating a breakpoint that will only
be hit if the length of my Mysteries
array is more than zero so I here only
want to stop when the API has actually
returned my data because I only actually
care about the data for this particular
debugging case I know that the API is
returning so I don't need to stop when
the API hasn't returned but the react
render is run so you can always click on
the pause on exceptions button if you
want a breakpoint when there's an error
and the tick box to pause on court
exceptions can be really useful for
instance if you've got a try-catch
that's swallowing your errors and you're
not sure why then you can find out more
about those exceptions when you have a
bunch of breakpoints in your app it can
be useful to disable one or more when
you're focused on something specific so
this check mark in the breakpoints list
here will just disable that breakpoint
temporarily and in the debugging toolbar
you can disable all breakpoints in case
you want to just check how your app runs
while you're checking some changes
you've made for example and a tool
that's really useful when you're using
the debugger is like boxing this lets us
prevent the debugger from stepping into
certain scripts when we're debugging
code so here I was debugging a reaction
lifecycle function and I jumped into the
react Dom library I can be pretty sure
that my bug is not in the react Dom
library so I blackbox the script
and this way next time I step through
into a function that comes from this
file the debugger will simply ignore it
and I can focus on my application code
you can also include file patterns in
the dev tool settings - black box entire
folders like node modules for example
another useful trick when you're really
unfamiliar with a code base is command +
backslash if you press this shortcut
when javascript is executing it will add
a breakpoint to the code straight away
and stop it executing you'll be able to
instantly see what is happening the
moment you press that shortcut and you
can also not add log points and chrome
dev tools which is essentially a console
log that you don't have to remember to
delete from your code the debugger won't
pause on these points but you'll still
get the results in the console another
really useful tool when debugging and
the dev tools is the snippets option
under the sources panel here you can
save your own code snippets to run in
the console and there are some really
great collections of snippets available
online in different libraries so one of
my favorites augments the console with a
function called console dot save which
you can use and pass anything to it
which then gets downloaded as a JSON
file this is really handy especially
when you have a big JSON object that you
want to open maybe in an IDE or you want
to send it to a colleague for example
another useful tool is live expressions
you can click the I icon here to type
something into the console and create a
live expression this pins it to the top
of the console and it updates real time
it can be really useful when something
in your code needs to respond to a
window width or scroll position for
example and you'll be able to see it
update as you scroll down the side so
what about when you want to actually
test some of your bug fixing hypotheses
well a really great feature in chrome is
called local overrides so here we go to
the sources panel and go to overheads
and we can set them up by selecting a
folder on in this case my desktop I
think and
[Music]
we then need to give chrome access to
that folder and then we can go and
change any of the code on this site for
example this part of the reddit website
and add whatever we want so I'm going to
add a background color of purple and now
if I go come and save you can see I've
got this little purple dot up here on
the file and then when i refresh the
changes I persisted which is really
really useful if I close the dev tools
and refresh the changes are gone
this approach is really useful for
making smallest changes to production
websites when you're trying to debug
something in particular when you want to
fix something quickly and you have a
reasonably good idea of where it is you
don't need to have your local
environment running you don't even have
to have the original code on your
computer this can be done with just
about any computer setup so what happens
when you want to go further and make
bigger changes that you not only want to
persist on browser refresh but persist
to your own project file sitting locally
on your computer well the diff tools
also have a really interesting feature
called workspaces so here's a little app
I made for calculating insulin dosage
for diabetics note it's a production app
on Heroku not on my localhost
so this could could be any website right
so in the file system tab I can add the
folder this is my actual folder on my
desktop for this application and again
give the dev tools access to it and now
you can see my applications loaded here
in the sources panel I'm gonna make a
change I'm just gonna add a console log
of hi why not and if I save that and go
to my IDE you can see that the file
itself has been updated and I can also
go back the other way so I'm gonna add
every one here and see that it's
persisted here to the dev tools this
could be super useful and really
powerful and in fact for some people it
allows them to use just the dev tools
debugger as a sorry dev tools as their
IDE however it can be a little flaky and
it's still not as good as a full idea in
my
opinion in particular it struggles with
more complicated build systems but if
you have a project that you built with
create react out or view so yeah CLA for
example you can actually just drag the
entire folder onto the sources panel and
it's all set up for you so if you like
this idea of being able to persist
changes on your production website
there's one last way I want to show you
this is the concept of proxying your
production files to local files on your
hard drive
similar to workspaces but without the
dev tools persistence but with a lot
more other features that better support
complicated build systems the simplest
is a Chrome extension called resource
overrate so say you have a version of
your application running on localhost
using this extension you could proxy the
call that your production website is
making in this case on the left hand
side bandolce is - the version of that
file and on your local drive so that's
my local host is and this allows you to
change your code and test it within the
larger environment where the bug
actually occurred applications like
fiddler and Charles proxy which is my
personal favorite also allow you to do
this but with a lot more features
including the ability to monitor and
inspect all the calls that your website
is making I've been on teams that have
literally used Charles proxy for their
entire front-end development flow many
big applications can be tricky to set up
locally and trying to keep the backend
architecture and api's up-to-date as
people are working on them as well as
your own front-end code base across
multiple teams can be a pain in the ass
that can take quite a lot of time if
however you have a reliable staging
environment that everyone's pushing to
then proxying your front-end files is a
nice way to skip that set up entirely so
a lot of the technology I'm covering
either is seriously enhanced by or
doesn't work at all without source Maps
so a source map is a file that allows
the browser or other technology to map
the compiled or compressed code back to
its original file it's a really
important tool that helps with debugging
minified code is almost impossible to
debug properly on the top we're
inspecting a website without source man
and you can see all the variables have
met beam angles and the ESX class has
been transposed whereas on the bottom
source maps have been setup and it's way
easier to understand what's going on
because it's the code we actually wrote
and depending on your build process it
should be pretty straightforward to set
up here's the config for web pack and at
the top is the way to tell web pack to
use its standard development
configuration which includes source maps
by default if you want more control you
can define it separately I've chosen
cheap module evil because I like the
balance between speed and support but
your choice will depend on your use case
then beneath that we have the config for
production and the only thing you
actually need here is the dev tool
property but if you're using uglify
jeaious to minify your code you'll want
to see it source map to true when you
declare that plug-in and if you want to
set the file name of the source map you
can get to when you build your project
you should see your source map file like
we have over on the right hand side so
what about deploying source maps to
production well I am a big believer in
doing this because production behaves
when you really want to know what's
going on you're in a hurry and you want
to decipher the code pretty quickly so
the good thing about source maps is that
they only get downloaded when the dev
tools are opened so then they have no
effect on your application or on its
performance and if you're really worried
about people being able to look at your
source code and a metaphor unhhhh
minified and keep in mind that security
through obscurity is never a good idea
then there's a pretty straightforward
solution so here you can indicate in the
javascript file a source map your source
mapping URL configurable with webpack
that points to the source map that's
been uploaded to a different location
say one that's only accessible by your
team like an s3 bucket
maybe that's only set up for your
company's VPN to access and if you're
not able to setup source maps say you're
just being nosy and checking out someone
else's website you can always click on
the format' button to make the code at
least slightly more readable so moving
on now to performance debugging and I do
not have time to do it justice
there's so much you can learn about here
and it's easily another entire talk but
I wanted to quickly illustrate where you
could start and the key is to find the
code that you wrote right
so these flame charts to be a little bit
indecipherable until you actually figure
out where your code is so if you click
to open the main panel you'll see all
the activity that occurred on the main
thread
including the execution of JavaScript
usually a lot of the stuff here is found
in frameworks but if you scan through
the orange sections you'll be able to
find your JavaScript files which is
usually what you're looking for right in
this case it's my main J's file and know
this is a very basic one page app which
is why it's so small you can then zoom
in further and find the functions in
your app and compare the time that
they're taking with each other here we
can see a call to app in child and fetch
which should be a little bit more
familiar to us and the easiest way to
debug in apps performance poor
performance is by doing a performance
audit with lighthouse this is a tool
inside the audits panel here you can see
the results on the same small one-page
app and the best bit here is the
opportunities section where they have a
where you've got a list of the resources
that you should optimize and it has
specific details on how to do so the
audits panel also allows you to order
other things like accessibility which is
really great it makes something so
important it's so much easier and if you
follow the expense the specific advice
in the audit your app will be so much
more usable for so many more people and
in many cases improve the experience
everyone keep in mind though there is no
substitute for proper manual
accessibility testing so when it comes
to debugging specific elements for their
accessibility the elements pane comes in
handy here you can inspect elements and
see which properties are correctly
filled out so in this case we're
inspecting a text input you can see that
the name property is searched and this
is what screen readers will read out
when the user focuses on this input you
can see that the name was computed by
looking at the placeholder property this
input should really have a proper label
or an area label but
at least it has a placeholder so all
users would now be able to know what
it's for rather than a screen reader
just reading out text input so the last
thing for the dev tools did you know
that you can even debug node in the dev
tools you just need to run your node
script with the inspect flag BR came by
the way it means break before the code
starts so that you can add your
breakpoints straight away then either
click on this green node icon down here
on the left or go to Chrome slash
inspect and click on open dedicated dev
tools for node if you like this workflow
you should check out the node inspection
manager extension which manages all your
scripts and work and windows for you so
let's get to the really good stuff
integrated debugging in the editor has
been around for ages but many JavaScript
developers are either not aware of it
they think it's too tricky to setup or
they don't want to change their
debugging mindset because they don't
think it's worth it well I'll let you be
the judge but do give it a go first
unfortunately we have a lot more
front-end editor options these days some
of which include an inbuilt debugger I'm
gonna focus on vs code because it's
super light and fast and it's what I use
every day and I promise I'm not trying
to sell you anything because well that
would be stupid because it's free but
yeah other ideas like webstorm also
include an inbuilt debugger and the idea
is pretty similar I'm gonna take you
through my debugging process and how I
set it up with a mini front-end react
app that talks to an express server
I've added a couple of spelling mistakes
to simulate a real bug that you might be
trying to fix so typical process for
debugging a front-end application might
look something like this we open the
browser we see an error in the console
we go to our editor we log out some of
the variables back to the browser and
refresh or maybe a hot module reloading
if we're lucky we've chosen a variable
that helps us determine how to fix the
bug back to the editor make the fix back
to the browser refresh okay great
perfect well that's a hell of a lot of
guesswork and switching back and forth I
mean we're we're used to it but but it
doesn't need to be this way vias code
has a bunch of extensions that let you
debug tons of different languages
in different configurations the most
useful for us is the debugger for Chrome
extension it's actually framework
agnostic so you could be working with
angular if you react whatever you like
but I'm going to show you the
configuration for my app so first of all
I'm going to the extensions and
searching for the debug of Chrome I'm
going to install that and reload vs code
and now I can go to configurations and
add a new configuration and I'm gonna
choose the launch Chrome one here and
I'm gonna change the URL to localhost
3000 because that's what create react
app uses by default and save that and
then press play and you can see that the
app is loaded there's absolutely no
other setup or settings it's really
really easy and the debugging experience
it's also really nice so here I have a
bug because there's supposed to be some
quotes showing up in my app and if I add
a debugging breakpoint about where I
think that the bug probably is and then
refresh I can see I've hit my breakpoint
and I can see that QWOP is undefined
I wonder why and if I go into the
variables here and inspect the actual
data I can see oh the data calls it
quote okay
well then I can go and edit the variable
fix the bug remove the breakpoint and
then restart and hey it's fixed and I
didn't even need to touch the browser
obviously this is a pretty fake example
but you get the idea
so before I finished I should just
quickly mention that in no way have I
covered the space I've obviously had to
focus on one browser and one IDE and I
didn't even touch on mobile and network
and Service Worker debugging to name a
few there is so much more to explore
here and of course accurate and
realistic test coverage is an extremely
important and useful way to prevent bugs
in the first place provide a quick and
easy way to test fixes and prevent them
from occurring again
the golden rule my golden rule
whenever you fix your bug make sure
there's a test for it so the last thing
I'm gonna leave you with is this if you
want to stick to the good old console
log then that's cool by me I still use a
combo of different tools including
console.log but please at least set
yourself up with a good code snippet so
you're not wasting your life typing it
out by hand every single time that's it
thank you
[Applause]